- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk a little
bit about segment congruence.
And what we have here, let's
call this statement one,
this is the definition of
line segment congruence,
or at least the one that we will use.
Two segments are congruent,
that means that we can map
one segment onto the other
using rigid transformations.
And examples of rigid
transformations are reflections,
rotations, translations,
and combinations of them.
Now what we're going to see in this video
is that statement one
is actually equivalent to statement two.
Or another way of saying it
is if statement one is true,
then statement two is true,
and if statement two is true,
then statement one is true.
Or we can write it like this,
we can map one segment onto another
using rigid transformations
if and only, only if,
the two segments have the same length.
So how do we go about proving it?
Well the first thing that
we'd want to prove is
that if statement one is true, then,
then statement two is true.
So how would we go about doing this?
And like always, I encourage you
to pause the video and have a go at it.
All right, now let's
work through it together.
Some proofs like this might be difficult
because they feel so intuitive.
But one way to prove this is
to first say that by definition
rigid transformations preserve length.
So by definition, by
definition, definition,
rigid transformations,
that's what makes them rigid,
rigid transformations preserve length.
So if one segment, if one segment,
can be mapped onto,
onto a second segment
with rigid transformations,
they must have had the original,
the same original length,
they must have had the
same original length,
they must have had same original length.
Or another way to say
it is, then two is true.
Then we can try to do
it the other way around.
So let's see if we can prove that if two,
if statement two is true,
then statement one is true,
then statement one, and why
don't you pause this video
and have a go at that as well.
So let's assume, assume, I have segment AB
and then I have another
segment, let's call it CD,
have the same length, have same length.
So they meet the number two
statement right over there.
To map, to map AB onto CD,
all I have to do, I can do this
in two rotations every time,
I first will, I will translate
so that A is on top of C,
so I will translate, translate AB,
so that point A is on top of point C.
And then the next thing
I would do is rotate,
rotate AB so that point B,
point B, is on top of point D.
And there you have it.
For any two segments with the same length,
I can always translate it
so that I have one set of points overlap,
and then to get the
other points to overlap
I just have to rotate it.
I know that's going to work
because they have the same length.
So I've just shown you,
if we can map one segment
onto another using rigid transformations,
then we know they have the same length,
and if two segments have the same length,
then we know that we can map one segment
onto the other using
rigid transformations.